This year, the average American
will spend nearly $600 on gift
cards — more than all other gifts combined.
Naturally, a few of those 198 billion dollars
will go unused. Cards get lost in the couch,
forgotten entirely, or a few pennies
here and there left as remainder.
Individually, these financial
leftovers are insignificant.
But collectively, they add up.
Starbucks, now as much a bank as a coffee shop,
held $181 million worth of stored credit in 2021.
And when Radio Shack declared bankruptcy,
it reported $46 million worth
of unredeemed gift cards.
Where does all that money go?
Common sense would say: the company’s pockets,
of course. Why else would gift cards be placed
in prominent, high-traffic parts of the store?
But… not necessarily. Quite often, unused
gift cards are commandeered by the state.
And not just any state. Not,
as you might reasonably assume,
the state where the card was purchased.
Nor, even, the home state of its buyer.
In reality, a significant portion
of all unclaimed gift cards,
across the entire United States,
regardless of where they were purchased,
are seized by just one state — the
second-smallest state, in fact — Delaware.
And its tiny population of one
million profits enormously.
Delaware is one of five states with no sales tax,
along with Alaska, Oregon,
Montana, and New Hampshire.
It also has one of the lowest
property taxes in the country.
Yet, despite collecting lower overall taxes
than any state except resource-rich Alaska,
Delaware spends more per-capita
than all but three others.
In other words, Delaware operates in
many ways like a tiny, profit-seeking,
rent-maximizing, oil-rich emirate. Rather than
being blessed with a natural resource like oil,
it’s been granted the near-exclusive legal right
to collect many of America’s unused gift cards.
Sponsored by Nebula, the exclusive home
to my Original series “China, Actually”.
Delaware is not the only
place that seizes unclaimed
property. All 50 states have laws of this variety.
When someone dies without heirs, for instance,
the state takes custody of their home.
If no rightful owner is found, it’s sold and
the proceeds redistributed to the public.
But this process, called “escheatment”, was
envisioned with physical property in mind.
As wealth became increasingly
intangible, things got complicated.
In 1965, four different states tried to claim the
same undeposited paychecks
from Sun Oil worth $26,000.
Texas, where the checks were issued,
conveniently argued the state which
had the “most significant contacts
with the debt” should receive them.
New Jersey, where the company
was legally incorporated,
argued it was entitled to the profits.
Because Sun Oil was headquartered in Pennsylvania,
it too made a play for the money, as the
debtor’s “principal place of business”.
Finally, Florida's claim was based on the
last-known address of the paycheck recipients.
The Supreme Court was charged with
deciding which of these rules to
sanctify with its gavel and pretend
wasn’t as arbitrary as the next.
In the end, the court did what courts are good at:
concealing the arbitrary nature
of its ruling with complexity.
The fairest solution, it
said, would be a compromise.
First, unclaimed property would be
assigned based, as Florida suggested,
on the recipient’s last-known address. In
the unlikely event none could be found,
it would simply revert to where the company
was incorporated — in this case, New Jersey.
But what the court failed to anticipate
was the monumental rise of gift cards.
Almost by definition, no one knows the
last-known address of the owner of a gift card.
After all, most gift cards
are… gifted to someone else.
In practice, therefore, unused
gift cards almost always belong
to the state in which the company is registered.
And that state is almost always Delaware.
This is the number of Fortune 500 companies
registered in each state as of 2018.
Virginia has 11, Ohio, 16, and New York, 20.
Now, watch what happens when we
add Delaware, at well over 300.
Delaware is to corporations what Liberia,
Panama, and the Marshall Islands are to ships.
…The only difference is that Liberia, Panama,
and the Marshall Islands have competition.
Whereas, 95% of businesses that incorporate
outside their home state choose Delaware.
The first and most obvious reason is money.
Delaware doesn’t tax “intangible investments”
like trademarks and patents, allowing companies
to transfer their mascots, logos, and
jingles to the state and save millions.
The second is speed.
An interaction with the Delaware
Division of Corporations would
blow the mind of anyone with the
misfortune of having visited a DMV.
If you’re willing to pay extra, you can form
your company in less than 30 minutes. And its
offices stay open until midnight, making life
easy for anyone in Dubai, Lagos, or Hong Kong.
Then, there’s the extreme anonymity.
You don’t need to prove your identity
to register a business in Delaware.
In fact, you don’t have to provide
your name, address, or phone number.
All the state requires is a single “contact
person”, who can be anyone 18 or older who
lives on planet Earth — whether or not they’re
a U.S. Citizen or even live in the country.
In theory, any state in the Union could offer
companies anonymity, speed, and low taxes.
But there’s one thing only Delaware has:
decades and decades of legal precedent.
The United States inherited from England two types
of courts: Common Law and Chancery — the latter of
which dealt with issues of fairness,
especially in the realm of property.
Since then, most states have merged the two into
one “Superior” court. Except three —
Tennessee, Mississippi, and Delaware.
Today, the Delaware Chancery Court is effectively
a separate justice system for corporations.
Instead of erratic juries, its decisions are
made by specialized judges who’ve
seen thousands of similar cases.
In other words, corporations choose
Delaware for its predictability.
Now, it may sound like the State of Delaware is
effectively colluding with Corporate America.
But… not exactly.
Sure, Delaware fights hard to attract companies.
But, at the same time, it’s hardly any
less profit-oriented than they are.
Once they’ve set up shop, it extracts
from them every last penny it can.
Needless to say, this near-monopoly on corporate
registration is extraordinarily profitable.
It collects more in corporate fees alone than
42 states collect in corporate income taxes.
But the State of Delaware is far
from satisfied. It wants more.
And that puts it on a collision
course with nearly everyone else.
Take gift cards, for instance.
Delaware interprets the 1965 Supreme Court ruling
as a license to collect virtually
all of America’s unused gift cards.
And it will aggressively fight any company
or even government that stands in its way.
Remember, the purpose of escheatment is, first and
foremost, to reunite lost property with its owner.
The state is a mere custodian
until a rightful heir is found.
Because it’s nearly impossible to track
down the rightful heir of a gift card,
many states have quite sensibly exempted them.
But it doesn’t matter. Delaware still claims
that money as its own — even when the company
in question has not a single office,
employee, or customer within its borders.
In other words, the States of
California, Texas, and New York,
for example, can’t decide what happens to the
unused gift cards sold in their own territory.
It’s as if Delaware could impose
an extraterritorial income tax
on residents of Nevada, where there isn’t one.
Its motive, of course, is revenue. Lots of it.
In 2001, the state discovered that less than 1%
of companies had reported unclaimed
property and decided to crack down.
It outsourced the enforcement of this
arcane law to four auditing firms.
These auditors, in turn, would reach out
to companies with a wildly-high “estimate”
of what they owed. If the company couldn’t
disprove this enormous number with 20 years
worth of documentation, it would
be forced to cough up the money.
While the State of Washington keeps its unclaimed
property forever and even has a staff of people
searching for its rightful owner, only
about 2% is ever returned in Delaware.
The rest, it simply spends.
Unclaimed property is Delaware’s
third-largest source of revenue,
behind only personal income
taxes and corporate fees.
In 2016, a federal judge ruled that
the state of Delaware was, quote,
“engaged in a game of ‘gotcha’
that shocks the conscience”.
The victims in this game are not only
corporations but the entire United States.
By delegating to states the power to register
corporations with no minimum standards,
the U.S. federal government
unleashed a race to the bottom.
…A race that would ultimately benefit
one state to the detriment of all others.
Then, in 1965, the Supreme Court further
tipped the scales in Delaware’s favor
by unintentionally granting it a virtual
monopoly on unclaimed corporate property.
Recall that its rationale, at the time,
was “fairness” to every state. The court didn’t
foresee how Delaware would weaponize its ruling.
And that’s how we got here.
Today, a state home to just 0.3% of
the U.S. population effectively sets
U.S. corporate law — a power it used
to propel the country to #1 on the
“Financial Secrecy Index” — above Switzerland,
Luxembourg, and the British Virgin Islands.
Thanks to Delaware, the United States of
America may be the best place to launder money.
Viktor Bout, one of the world’s most
notorious arms traffickers and inspiration
for the 2005 film “Lord of War” set up
dozens of shell companies in Delaware.
The state became a sanctuary
for the profits he made selling
weapons used in wars throughout Afghanistan, Iran,
and Syria — years-long and absolutely brutal
conflicts which remain poorly understood today.
And Modern Conflicts — a nearly 30-episode Nebula
Original series by RealLifeLore — traces each
of these wars from their very inception to
the present day, telling stories that could
only be told on an independent platform like
Nebula, free from the threat of demonetization.
Thanks to the creative freedom offered by Nebula,
Neo was able to make this investigation into
flight MH17, Tech Altar, this critical look
at how 9/11 changed cinema, and me,
this deeper look at how China works.
but you also get access to Nebula Classes for no
extra cost, where you can take a behind-the-scenes
look at your favorite creators. There are no ads
or sponsors and many videos are available early.
If you sign up today, you can get Nebula for
40% off with the annual plan — that’s just
$2.50 a month for both Nebula and Nebula Classes
with the link on screen or in the description.